[Music]
hey guys it's me Issa Rae and I am
joined by our incredibly talented show
on Apprentice penny for another season
of our wind down so the code open ends
with ISA saying she doesn't ever Bobby
no more how does this set the tone for
the new season we've been building -
Ethan Molly meeting to have a
conversation and we want the audience to
be like what what did I miss our show is
known as you know for ISA he says
Molly's relationship they aren't legit
friends they're girls they arrive for
each other we wanted to stretch a
question are these friendships or
relationships for a reason or for a
season so one of the things that's a big
deal is how everybody's like leveling up
this hearing well II said Molly start
off as we see them together taking care
of themselves and I think ISA more so
than Molly has decided to focus on
nothing but good vibes making sure that
her career or her passion is in order
and not letting distractions take her
away from that I think it also to like
what we've done to that thing tried to
flip the season a little bit the
dynamics we're like Oh ISA has a lot of
work and situations and Bali is having
more personal VIN issues they tasked
each other to hold each other
accountable and we found out at the end
of the episode that maybe Lisa's not
ready for Molly to holders so
accountable and to be so truthful it's
almost like be careful what you wish for
yeah so throughout this series we
haven't seen Molly be in a long-term
relationship inherently her nature is to
want to be booed up I think she's
fighting yeah that energy to want to do
that and I think when she realizes like
oh he's dating - which is what you said
you were doing it's like I don't really
want you to be out there exactly
despite her denials she's invested in
Andrews at this point and I think it was
a big step for her to text him yeah and
I'm curious like why do you think Molly
comes for ISA after finding out that
she's gonna continue working with
gondola despite the fact that condolence
dating Laurens
Molly knowing
three I think she knows more about Issa
and Lawrence's relationship than anyone
Molly knows it is ultimately gonna be
affected by this Molly knows all this
stuff about you as a friend
and kadoya does know Amy and those
energy is just too when they're doing
you up so that's infectious right like
you're already feeling like plenty this
is a lot yeah here comes this woman
bleeding you while this other friend is
kind of like no this is a mess that is
so real - and we talked about this and
the rumors that Issa is the type of
person to feed off of people putting
that kind of energy like she needs that
to kind of succeed sometimes you need
stupidity around you because like the
first person to fly yeah why do you feel
Issa has the need to tell these
potential sponsors different versions of
what the black party should be Issa is
always just trying to sell some [ __ ]
it's just honesty is not her favorite
policy and I think that this comes from
this feeling of like maybe my event
isn't good enough maybe I'm not the
right person to do this so I need to
tell them what they want to hear as
opposed to having them buy into I and
because maybe who I am
isn't enough you know in the end they
bought into her like you're throwing an
event like this nobody's like really
like oh this event is the dopest thing
or this is the best idea they're really
looking at you yeah you're like what is
it about you that I should put my money
behind and I think she realizes that
later this is a good seat there's gonna
be good thank you for hanging out with
us tonight see you next week this way
cheers Cheers
[Music]
you